to go back to your example of robin
williams i don't know what was going on
inside him i don't know the nature of
his internal state was it a was it
active psychic pain that
man mentioned may interrupt to just say
that sergey posted an examination of
robin williams's brain tissue suggested
that he suffered from quote diffuse
l-e-w-y lewy body dementia
lbd depression is a symptom of lbd and
it's not about psychology it's rooted in
urology this is words from
his brain was falling apart yeah lewy
body dementia this is a very interesting
neurological disorder where
among other things there are there's
neuron death indeed so you've got frank
neuron loss it's not just a matter of
some long-standing
psychic pain but you've got a
progressive
loss and so clearly you've got a
situation where he could have finally
reached a point where
the balance that he'd worked out between
negativity and positivity uh
was disrupted due to loss the wrong
cells died the wrong projections were
cut by the lewy body dementia certainly
dopamine neurons die in lewy body
dementia those are neurons that give
rise to
much of the feelings of reward and
pleasure that we experience among other
roles
so
uh clearly in his case there could have
been a very
concrete cellular neurological issue
that was progressive and pushed him to
that point
but what were you uh
were you about to make a point about
broader that if there isn't another
neurological degeneration yeah so in his
case not knowing that uh
it could have been simply that let's say
he had
an internal psychic pain state and it
was in
he was in sort of a compensated mode for
much of his life able to generate enough
joy from his comedy and his social
interactions and
and then but eventually later in life
you know the
the those things drop away the balance
shifts you get tired of fighting the
pain for that long and then so you've
got this time dependent
non-stationarity that happens and then
the same
symptom becomes no longer tolerable in
the end
you